we're at 408 on your labor day monday  what's driving you crazy well we got  another one of many viewer emails about  horrible driving around elementary  schools  lydia's complaints could be from any of  the clark county school districts more  than 200 elementary schools so even  though the pictures here from the ccsd  police department's funny not funny  facebook page are not from the school  that she's talking about they sure could  be she writes  every single day i witness speeding  illegal u-turns and double parking near  tomayasu elementary and annie oakley and  rawhide how do we get police to come  ticket these crazy drivers  well lydia i cannot guarantee that the  ccsd pd will get out to tommy yasuo but  i'm passing her in for along thanks for  taking the time to ride in buckle up  drive carefully please put down that  phone you can join the drive and you  crazy conversation at traffic eight at  eightnewsnow.com